si tu continues à faire ce que tu as
toujours fait tu continueras être ce que
tu as toujours été je partage une
cellule avec un mec qui avait c'est beau
tatoué sur la poitrine en caractères
japonais après dix ans le mec est sortie
une semaine après il s'est fait
descendre pour avoir continué d'être ce
qu'il a toujours été
dieu nous étape
delphi s'est dit qu'est ce que tu sais
exactement de tempérer mois vous étiez
les meilleurs amis associés vous étiez
des escrocs les meilleurs de la ville
d'après les anciens
normal
j'arrive pas à me souvenir de la
dernière chose dont j'ai été fier
john sacré compétences qui pourraient
m'être très utile d'un mois du mars
je suis en train de monter une arnaque
pour le samaritain j'ai le pigeon
partait deux millions et demi de dollars
ça pourrait être tous élèves j'ai besoin
d'une chambre d'hôtel classe pour me
remettre en forme et où je pourrai
régler les détails de la remarque d'une
femme pour faire là bas et j'ai besoin
d'un endroit où la maxe déroulera là on
est sur la même longueur d'onde
assassine on est pas associée j'en ai eu
à une fois je les paie
je croyais que j'allais faire quoi de
pardonner d'avoir twin merde
ceci est une arme savez-vous qui je suis
je sais exactement qui vous êtes
qu'est ce que tu as des personne n'ira
nulle part rappelle me
rien de sens tant qu'on n'y change rien